moi je ne me lève pas faire c'est comme
ça amo game au caractère à cons ça c'est
bien c'est une petite répétition alors
qu en martinique pour la promotion de
ton album rio ce titre quatre autres
types pourquoi ben 14 titres l'album
live de pag annoncer l'album de toute
une carrière
parce qu'il faut savoir que j'ai plus de
28 ans de carrière que j'ai fêté en
grande pompe au zéphyr en janvier 2017
il te renvoie si je suis parti
[Musique]
retour j'ai beaucoup l'amour n'est pas
bon jouer des mauvais tours
[Musique]
j'en avais là
avant les méchants l'eau j'en avais
marre des coûts révolte un lourd passif
et les points faibles par clément
dhainaut
fallait tout ça mon était là ali met
dife et essence
alors oui c'est le pic est donc si on
veut mais c'est d'abord l'histoire
l'histoire banale des hommes et des
femmes à l'histoire d'amour à l'imed
c'est l'homme les sens et qui sait nous
les femmes
et puis quoi mais pour faire un bon show
pour faire belle histoire d'amour y fait
un bon feu ben le bon sens et ça c'est
la limite et naissance le bond soudain
mort d'un homme d'une femme
c'est à l'âge de 15 ans avec le groupe
les ballons tout à fait j'ai commencé à
15 ans avec koné kabir bas dit rob alors
ou d'un groupe à l'autre a fêté ses 40
ans d'existence et suite à ça j'ai été
remarqué par des saint rémy décembre qui
m'a demandé d'intégrer le groupe
mythique des mécènes chez nana et donc
je suis quand même la première femme
avant chanter chez nana dans un carnaval
je suis pas gays n'ont pas gagné c'est
tout bateau alors paganon j'ai créé ce
groupe pendant que j'étais avec les blue
stars en 2010 parce que j'avais envie de
faire autre chose
le jeudi le jeudi donc j'ai créé un
petit groupe de copains d'un million
étaient neuf sur scène et puis on
s'éclatait le jeudi et en 2011 quand
j'ai quitté les blues star a décidé de
propulser pagano et bien au niveau parce
que j'estimais que parraine on avait son
mot à dire
tout comme les mécènes les booster les
autres groupes de guyane donc je pense
que et puis depuis et ben en fait plus
de huit ans que l' aventure a commencé
et elle continue et ma foi de très belle
façon 2018 2019 au lan a décidé de
promouvoir la guyane tout à fait tout à
fait j'estime que depuis 2011
à croire que telle et booster donc avec
pagaie non on sillonne la guyane ancien
la guyane de long en large et en travers
parce que on s'est rendu compte que tous
les groupes étaient sur la capitale
alors nous a dit d'aller dans les
communes
j'ai envie d'exploiter ehpad et non
ailleurs ailleurs alors depuis à barry
bonds 2019 pour la désinence est prévue
on va vraiment aller plus qu'ailleurs on
ira effectivement sur le bateau on ira
sur un bateau on ira en croisière une
croisière touloulou tololo avec paraît
non monsieur granier est venu en guyane
il ya quelques années et il m'a vu
chanter ooh
canal est d'ailleurs l'idée parce que je
crois qu'il ya plusieurs croisières à
thème des croisés a réglé les croisières
ou les croisières de l'évangile et
pourquoi pas le croiser à toulouse
tholot est à l'initiative de cette
croisière est ma faim on le rend on le
remercie et ça va se passer comme ça il
y aura cette soirée il y aura cette
soirée mais sur le sec ce soir et cette
nuit du bateau il y aura cinq soirées
deux soirées de l'eau et trois soirées
tout
pour ce faire faire à néma trop
pour ce faire je forme et man je suis de
l'amazone au combat moi je fais